THANKS EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE HERE -- FIRST LIST OF
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIRTY RAZA.
YES THERE NIELSEN THEY'RE ON
BURKE.
OKAY OF THANK YOU WE WILL NOW GO
TO THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR.
I'M AND WE ARE GOING TO PULL.
ITEM NUMBER NINE ON THE VOTE
ONLY CALENDAR AND BUT THAT IN
OUR NEXT AGENDA.
SO BASED ON THAT.
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC.
COMMENT ON THESE ITEMS BEFORE WE
VOTE [inaudible]
OKAY.
HEARING NONE I'M WE CAN HAVE
SOME SEPARATE BOATS HERE ON EACH
OF THOSE.
SO FIRST WE WILL TAKE A VOTE ON
ISSUE.
ONE BY ITSELF SEPARATELY.
SO UP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
TURNED AROUND SO I THEIR NIELSEN.
THERE ARE BURKE.
THANK YOU.
OKAY NOW WILL CAN TAKE ISSUE.
FOR AN ISSUE. FIFTEEN TWO
SEPARATE ITEMS WERE VOTING
TOGETHER ON THEM.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CENTER AGA I CENTER NIELSEN NO.
THERE ARE BURKE.
OKAY NOW WE'RE GOING ON TO ISSUE.
FOURTEEN AND WE'RE SPLITTING
THAT INTO TWO SEPARATE VOTES.
THE FIRST VOTE OUT WILL BE ON
THE ENHANCED INFRASTRUCTURE
DISTRICT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
PLEASE CALL THE BOAT
[inaudible]
ROLL [inaudible]
RAZA.
THERE NIELSEN THANKS SIR I'M
BURKE
-- YES LET ME JUST CLARIFY
THAT -- I VOTE MEANS WERE
FOLLOWING THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION.
SO AS I UNDERSTAND [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YEAH.
AS I UNDERSTAND STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO REJECT IT
WITHOUT PREJUDICE.
BASICALLY I WOULD LOVE FOR THE
TIME BEING THE CORRECT.
ALL RIGHT.
IF YOU'LL CALL THE ROLL ONE MORE
TIME.
CENTER I'M BURKE [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- OKAY THE SECOND
VOTE ON ISSUE FOURTEEN WILL BE
ON THE SEAT WHATEXEMPTION.
OR HOMELESS SHELTERS AND
NAVIGATION CENTERS.
THIS CALL THE ROLL.
CENTER RAZA I CENTER NIELSEN.
CENTER I'M BURKE [inaudible]
NO NO.
NOW WE'RE TAKING UP ISSUES
[inaudible] TO THREE AND FIVE
THREE THIRTEEN EXCEPT.
FOR NINE OKAY BECAUSE WE WE HAD
PULLED NINE OUT.
SO TWO THREE AND FIVE FIVE SIX
SEVEN EIGHT TO THIRTEEN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
SO WILL BE CLEAR ON ITEM NUMBER.
TWO AND IN AN AYE VOTE IS TO
SUPPORT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION.
WHICH IS NOT [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
CENTER RAZA HI -- NELSON CENTER
A BURKE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY WE'VE GONE OUT TO ISSUE
[inaudible]
SIXTEEN OKAY.
ALL RIGHT ISSUE SIXTEEN IS A
FRANCHISE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
WITH.
IN OUR OWN BIRDS [inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
AND THIS IS ON THE SCALE
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
TIFFANY WE SPENT.
OR IF THIS CAL [inaudible]
THIS PROPOSAL. FOUR MILLION.
NINE STATION.
AND DECISIONS IN THE OPENING
TWENTY IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FISCAL YEARS. TO
FULLY ADOPT THE FINANCIAL
INFORMATION SYSTEM FOR
CALIFORNIA OR FISCAL.
IN TO COMPLY WITH STATEWIDE
ACCOUNTING POLICIES WITHIN
MANDATED TIME FRAME.
WELL FISCAL BRINGS TRANSPARENCY
INCONSISTENCY IT INTRODUCED
COMPLEXITY TO F. T. BASIC.
PROCUREMENT PROCESSES.
THESE INCREASE COMPLEXITIES HAVE
RESULTED IN INCREASED VOLUMES
ADDITIONAL TESTS IN ADDITIONAL
TIME REQUIRED TO COMPLETE
TRANSACTIONS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN F. TV
BEGAN ACTIVELY WORKING WITH THE
SCALE THE PLAN DESIGN AND TEST
NEW PROCESSES.
PROCEDURES WORK CLOTHES IN
INFORMATION HAND OFFS.
FTV WENT LIVE IN FISCAL IN JULY
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND HAS
BEEN TRANSACTING IN THE SYSTEM
FOR TEN MONTHS.
FTV IS SUBSTANTIALLY PASSED IN
THE LEARNING CURVE ISSUES AND
THIS PROPOSAL REQUEST RESOURCES
TO SUPPORT STANDARD DAY TO DAY
OPERATIONS IN ACCOUNTING AND
PROCUREMENT.
WE'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS -- BECAUSE LA -- HAVE
ANY [inaudible]
COMMENTS.
RAINY WEATHER FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
HAVE NO COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
BROWN RELIGION TO BERMAN OF
FINANCED IS A CRITICAL RESOURCES
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
AND THIS IS NOT WITH RESPECT TO
THIS PARTICULAR ITEM BUT OF
MANAGER YOU AND I'VE DISCUSSED
ON A NUMBER OF OCCASIONS THE
PLEX CITY OF THIS PROJECT AND
THE THAT.
WE WE I THINK WE NEED.
TO VISIT THIS.
AND THE ANOTHER HEARING INTO A
DEEPER DIVE IN TERMS OF FISCAL
IN GENERAL.
ANOTHER DAY NOW.
THANK YOU -- OKAY -- I AM WITH A
QUESTION OF AND MAYBE THIS IS
FOR ANOTHER DAY AS WELL BUT WITH
REGARDS TO THIS PARTICULAR.
REQUEST.
THESE INCREASED RESOURCES OF DO
YOU WHAT DO YOU SAY ABOUT THE
THE ISSUES THAT THE DEPARTMENT
HAS EXPERIENCED WILL THEY BE
RESOLVED OR ARE THERE GOING TO
BE PROBLEMS BEYOND THE RESOURCES
AND OTHERS WITH THE RESOURCES
THAT YOU'RE ASKING.
FOR RESOLVE THESE PROBLEMS
INTERESTED I'M THESE RESOURCES
ARE.
THE RESOURCES WE REQUESTED ARE
SPECIFIC TO THE WORKLOAD THAT WE
EXPECT TO SEE AND ARE SEEN WITH
THIS GAL -- WE ARE EXPERIENCING
SOME SYSTEM CHALLENGES BUT
OUTSIDE OF THAT THESE RESOURCES
ARE SPECIFIC TO THE WORK WE
EXPECT.
FINANCE YOUR QUESTION SO THAT A
YES OR NO.
YES THESE RESOURCES WILL ADDRESS --
WILL ADDRESS THE WORKLOAD
HOWEVER WE ARE EXPERIENCING
SYSTEM CHALLENGES THAT WE ARE
ENGAGING WITH FISCAL TO RESOLVE
IF THOSE CONTINUE WE WE WILL
HAVE ISSUES WITH THOSE.
OKAY I'M NOT SURE HOW.
TO SO THERE ARE OTHER PROBLEMS
THANK YOU FORESEE THERE'S THAT
WE HAVE TO PAY MORE THAT YOU
ALREADY HAVE IDENTIFIED WE HAVE
TWO PRIMARY PRIMARY DRIVERS BUT
THEY'RE CHALLENGES RIGHT NOW ONE
IS CLOSING OUR OUR MONTHS.
AND OUR CHALLENGE WITH CLOSING
OR MONTHS OR SOME SYSTEM ISSUES
WHICH WE EXPECT TO WORK OUT
WEARING TEACHING WITH FISCAL
RIGHT NOW ON THOSE.
THESE RESOURCES ARE FOR THE
INCREASED WORK THAT THEY I
TALKED ABOUT WHAT THE INCREASED
VOLUME THE INCREASED COMPLEXITY
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS TO THESE
RESOURCES WILL ADDRESS THOSE
SPECIFIC ISSUES -- THE SYSTEM
COMPONENT OF IT WE ARE ENGAGE
WITH THIS GIRL WE EXPECT THOSE
TO RESULT IS THAT BETTER INTO
YOUR QUESTION.
WELL DO YOU HAVE A SENSE OF
YOU'RE.
THINKING YOU'RE GONNA FIND OR
YOU WITH YOUR ALREADY
IDENTIFYING.
I MEAN IS IT'S A MATTER OF
ANOTHER SIX MONTHS OR IS IT A
YEAR OR IS IT.
IS THAT WOULD THAT BE A MATTER
OF STAFFING ALSO TO RESOLVE IT
WHAT'S YOUR SENSE OF WHERE THIS
IS ALL GOING AS FAR AS REALLY
RESOLVING THE ISSUE.
IN TERMS OF THE SYSTEM ISSUES
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING STAFFING
THAT WE HAVE CAN RESOLVE -- IT'S
IT'S A SYSTEM -- CHALLENGE THAT
WE'RE RUNNING INTO -- AND SO I
WOULD TO FIX THAT A CONTINUING
TO ENGAGE WITH THIS GIRL.
HI.
OKAY SO THAT'S THE THAT'S WHAT
STILL ON RESULT CORRECT.
YES YOU CAN LOOK FOR I DON'T
THINK THAT'S SUFFICIENT THIS IS
AN AREA OF GREAT IMPORTANCE.
IT'S AN AREA THAT.
THE WHOLE AREA IS EMBARRASSING
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ENORMOUSLY.
IS IT ACTUALLY EQUIPMENT
[inaudible]
OR SCHEDULING.
OR WHAT WHAT WHAT IS THE PROBLEM
THERE'S THERE'S CONNECTIVITY.
WE CAN'T SPEAK THE
RECONNAISSANCE A SYSTEM WE WERE
IF USERS OF THE SYSTEM SO WE CAN
SPEAK TO WHAT WE SEE IS WHEN WE
CLOSE A MONTH -- THERE CERTAIN
IN AN EXAMPLE.
TWO FLAVORS WHEN WE CLOSE A
MONTH BUT WE NEED TO DO IS SET
OFF CERTAIN SYSTEM PROCESS -- TO
CLOSE THAT MONTH WHEN YOU SET
OFF THOSE PROCESSES WE ENCOUNTER
IN ERROR.
AND WHICH WHICH PREVENTS IT SO
THAT IS WHAT WE NEED TO ENGAGE
WITH WITH HIS CAL TO RESOLVE
THOSE ERRORS.
THE PROBLEM IS WITH THE PROVIDER.
OR IS IT WILL PROVIDERS
EQUIPMENT.
I CAN'T SPEAK TO THAT.
ALSO AT THIS POINT MAYBE I CAN
JUMP IN AND SAY SO AFTER BE JUST
RECENTLY FINISHED A VERY LARGE
MODERNIZATION EFFORT --
THROUGHOUT THAT EFFORT THAT
NGUYEN IMPLEMENTATION --
PROBLEMS POP UP AND YOU HAVE TO
PUT ALL HANDS ON DECK TO FIX
THOSE PROBLEMS.
AND THEY CAN BE VERY VERY TO
NOTS KIND OF THE STATE THAT MS
CALLOUS AND RIGHT NOW.
I'M AND I THINK LATE ON THE
AGENDA YOU'LL HEAR FROM FISCAL
THEMSELVES AND HOPEFULLY THEY'RE
ABLE TO ANSWER SOME OF YOUR
POINTED QUESTIONS BOOTS ON THE
GROUND.
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE WHAT WE
KNOW TODAY -- WITH THE INCREASED
CHANGES IN THE TASK AND REVIEW
PROCESSES AND AND PROCESSING
TIME.
THE RESOURCES THAT WE ASK OUR
SUFFICIENT ENOUGH TO COVER THOSE
ONGOING.
SO THERE COULD BE SURPRISES IN
CHANGES THAT HAPPEN BECAUSE OF
ISSUES THAT ARE OUTSTANDING THAT
ARE PREVENTING US FROM CLOSE IN
OUR BOOKS IN SOME WAY.
BUT NOT AS COMPLETELY UNKNOWN
AND WE ARE HOPEFUL.
THAT THERE IS A TECHNOLOGY
SOLUTION THAT WILL EVENTUALLY BE
FOUND AND PUT IN PLACE THAT WILL
ALLOW US TO BE FULLY AUTOMATED
IN THE ISSUES THAT ARE
OUTSTANDING.
ON THAT DISCOUNT CAN SUPPORT
THAT AUTOMATION AND THAT WE WILL
NOT NEED ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
FOR THAT.
NOT LEóN EMPLOYER FUNDS TO YOU
DON'T EXPECT ME TO BE
SYMPATHETIC.
I'M GOING IN WITH A NEGATIVE
ATTITUDE SO.
IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE CONVINCING
OF ME.
OKAY -- IS THERE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS [inaudible]
NO -- OKAY THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO APPROVE AS
A BUDGET IS THERE A MOTION
[inaudible]
OKAY -- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CENTER DORADO HI THERE NOTHING.
THERE ARE BURKE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
AND WORK HARD.
WE SELL THE FIFTH.
NEXT DEPARTMENT OF THIS IS ISSUE.
SEVENTEEN OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH
-- PLANNING RESEARCH
GOOD MORNING MORNING WELCOME.
MORNING AS CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LOUISE
BEDWORTH I'M EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL.
WE REQUESTED THREE POSITIONS AND
FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
I'M GOING SUPPORT FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO CONTINUE THE
EXISTING HEALTH AND ALL POLICIES
PROGRAM AT THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL.
ALSO KNOWN AS HIGH UP.
I THE HIGHER PROGRAM IS BEEN A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT BETWEEN
PHILANTHROPY AND THE STATE SINCE
IT'S A SEPT INCEPTION ABOUT TEN
YEARS AGO.
THE INTENTION OF THIS
COLLABORATION HAS BEEN TO
DEMONSTRATE HOW COLLABORATIVE
CROSS AGENCY PARTNERSHIP CAN
ADVANCE POSITIVE HEALTH OUTCOMES.
BY TOUCHING ON ALL OF THE
FACTORS THAT AFFECT HEALTH.
ALSO KNOWN AS THE SOCIAL TO
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
BECAUSE OF ITS CROSSCUTTING
NATURE EXECUTIVE ORDER S. O. FOR
TEN ESTABLISH THE HEALTH NOT
POLICIES TASK FORCE.
AS AN INITIATIVE OF THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL.
AS YOU SEE WAS ESTABLISHED IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT TO FACILITATE
CROSS AGENCY COLLABORATION. TO
ADVANCE SUSTAINABLE EQUITABLE
AND HEALTHY COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT CALIFORNIA.
SINCE THAT TIME THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE HAS SERVED AS A
FISCAL AGENT AND PROVIDED
HIDEOUTS STAFF. TO THE STATE
USING PHILANTHROPIC DOLLARS.
THIS PARTNERSHIP HAS ENABLED THE
PROGRAM TO BE ENTREPRENEURIAL
AND IDENTIFY EFFECTIVE WAYS TO
ENGAGE IN SUPPORT THE STATE.
HOWEVER THE LONG TERM GOAL OF
BOTH PHILANTHROPY AND AS SHE SEE
HAS BEEN TO SEE THIS
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH
INSTITUTIONALIZED IN THE STATE
STRUCTURE.
HOWEVER SAID WE KNOW NOW THAT
STAFFING FOR THE PROGRAM WILL
NOT CONTINUE BEYOND TO SUMMER
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AS FUNDING
WILL NO LONGER BE PROVIDED TO PH
I HEARD PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE.
BY FOUNDATION PARTNERS.
THE FOUNDATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED HAVE BEEN PLEASED WITH
THE SUCCESS AND EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE HIGHER PROGRAM.
THAT HAVE BEEN CLEAR FROM THE
BEGINNING THAT THEIR INVESTMENT
HAS BEEN INTENDED TO SUPPORT
START UP AND NOT LONG TERM
PROGRAMMANAGEMENT AND THE STATE
PROGRAM.
FOUNDATIONS HAVE INVESTED OVER
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS TODAY.
IN RCENT COMMUNICATIONS THEY
NOTED THAT HIGH UP HAS
SUCCESSFULLY DEMONSTRATED THE
VALUE AND IMPORTANCE OF
CALIFORNIANS INCORPORATING
HEALTH AND EQUITY IN
IMPLEMENTING STATE POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS.
AND THEY WOULD LIKE TO SEE
PROGRESS THIS YEAR IN
INSTITUTIONALIZING HI IT PROGRAM
AS AN ONGOING FUNCTION WITHIN
STATE GOVERNMENT.
WITH STATE RESOURCES.
AT AS SHE SEE HAIFA SUPPORTED
SEVERAL IMPORTANT INITIATIVES
THAT ARE HELPING FOR FILL OUR
STATUTORY DIRECTION IN MISSION
TO SUPPORT CROSS AGENCY
COLLABORATION.
INCLUDING CONVENING THE HEALTH
AND ALL POLICIES TASK FORCE
WHICH PROVIDES A FORUM FOR
COLLABORATION.
AND ALSO PRODUCES ACTION PLANS
IT OUTLINES OPPORTUNITIES
INTEGRATE HEALTH ACROSS
DEPARTMENTAL ACTIVITIES.
THE INTEGRATION OF HEALTH
INEQUITY AND AS SHE SEES
PROGRAMS.
I ADVANCES OUR OUTCOMES ALIGNED
WITH THE STATE'S CLIMATE CHANGE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND PUBLIC HEALTH
GOALS.
AND THEN MOST RECENTLY HI
HAPPENS BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN
PILOTING.
AT THE GOVERNMENT ALLIANCE ON
RACE AND EQUITY THE FIRST EVER
STATE LEVEL CO COURT ESTABLISHED
TO ADDRESS INSTITUTIONALIZED
RACISM ACROSS STATE PROGRAMS AND
PRACTICES.
INSTITUTIONALIZING HIGH UP WITH
STATE FUNDING IS CRITICAL TO
HELPING US YOU SEE FOR PHILLIPS
MISSION TO STRENGTHEN THE
ECONOMY AND ENSURE SOCIAL EQUITY
AND ENHANCE ENVIRONMENTAL
STEWARDSHIP ACROSS THE STATE.
I'M JOINED TODAY BY JULIA KAPLAN
PROGRAM MANAGER FOR HIGH UP.
JULIE IS LED THIS WORK FROM THE
BEGINNING AND IS FACILITATED
THIS PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
HERE THIS MORNING ARE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU ALL
HAVE.
THANK YOU WELCOME [inaudible]
IT'S AN I AM -- HERE WITH LOUISE
I IT SO I AM THE PROGRAM MANAGER
FOR HEALTH AND ALL POLICIES I'M
EMPLOYED BY PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE AND HAVE BEEN WORKING.
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL AND THE OTHER
HEALTH AND ALL POLICIES TASK
FORCE AGENCIES FOR THE LAST NINE
YEARS.
AND I AM ALSO HEARING AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OKAY
THANK YOU -- OKAY THE LA YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS NO FINANCE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
QUESTION THIS YEAR CHIEF MUCH
THUS FAR THE BENCH MARKS HE
ACTUALLY CHIEF MUCH DO YOU HAVE
A LIST OF FIVE TEN TWO THINGS
THAT HAVE BEEN BEEN DONE AND
ACCOMPLISHED IN THE BANK WORK.
BILL FROM.
WE THOUGHT YOU MIGHT ASK ABOUT --
WELL IT IT WAS REALLY A SPEAK TO
SOME OF THE SPECIFICS A LOT OF
THE WORK HAS BEEN REALIZED
THROUGH ACTION PLANS -- THAT
HAVE LOOKED ACROSS STATE
PROGRAMS IDENTIFY WAYS TO IN BAD
HEALTH AND REALLY.
LEVERAGE THE EXPERTISE OF THE PH
I TEAM -- AND OTHER PARTNERS AND
SO IT'S BEEN A VERY EFFICIENT
WAY TO START INFUSING HEALTH
THROUGH IT THROUGHOUT A NUMBER
OF PROGRAMS AND SO DELAYED CAN
PROVIDE SOME SPECIFIC EXAMPLE
YEAH I CAN PROVIDE A FEW
EXAMPLES IN IN THAT BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL. ONE OF THE
APPENDIX DOCUMENTS AT THE TABLE
THAT LISTS SOME SPECIFIC
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
BUT A FEW OF THEM HAVE BEEN AND
REALLY THAT THE PURPOSE OF
HEALTH AND ALL POLICIES IS NOT
TO CREATE NEW PROGRAMS IT'S
REALLY.
TO ENHANCE EXISTING PROGRAMS AND
HELP THOSE ACHIEVE MORE GOALS
WITH THE SAME DOLLARS AND SO.
OUT OUR TEAM HAS BEEN ABLE TO
PROVIDE INPUT TO GRANT PROGRAMS
ACROSS A WIDE VARIETY OF
DEPARTMENTS BRINGING HEALTH AND
EQUITY OPPORTUNITIES AND LANDS
TO OVER TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
GRANTS THAT HAVE GONE OUT TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
WE HAVE PROVIDED HEALTH INPUT
INTO THE STATE'S THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
IS.
GENERAL PLAN GUIDELINES WHICH
ARE THEN USED BY LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO DEVELOP THEIR
GENERAL PLANS AND SIMILARLY
PROVIDED SIGNIFICANT.
HEALTH AND EQUITY CONSULTATION
TO YOU THAT CTC AND CALTRANS
AROUND THE REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION.
PLANNING GUIDELINES SO IT'S BEEN
A LOT OF BRINGING THESE HEALTH
AND EQUITY PRINCIPLES IN TO WORK
THAT'S ALREADY HAPPENING AND
STRENGTHENING.
THOSE PARTNERSHIPS OF THESE
PRINCIPLES ARE ELEMENTS OF THE
QUOTE ACTION PLAN CORRECT.
THAT'S RIGHT AND IS THE ACTION
PLAN PUT FORTH IN THE DRAMA
DEPARTMENT OPERATION MANUAL OR
IS IT A REGULATION OR HOW DOES
IT.
WORK WITH THEM AS WELL AS WITH
LOCAL COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDERS TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE THEIR
PRIORITIES LIE AND WHERE THE
OPPORTUNITIES LIE IN TERMS OF
IMPROVING.
PROMOTION OF HEALTH AND EQUITY
OUTCOMES.
AND THEN WE DEVELOP ACTION PLANS
WITH THE DEPARTMENTS WHICH UP
UNTIL NOW HAVE BEEN VOLUNTARY.
SO IT'S REALLY LOOKING FOR THESE
AREAS OF POTENTIAL BENEFITS OR
WHERE SOME DEPARTMENTS HAVE
STRENGTHS THAT OTHERS DON'T AND
WE PROVIDE A FORUM FOR SHARING
OF BEST PRACTICES SHARING OF
TOOLS.
EXCHANGE OF INFORMATION ABOUT
MEASUREMENT STRATEGIES THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS THE ACTION PLANS
ARE -- WAY OF SUMMARIZING WHERE
THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES ARE AND
BASICALLY OUTLINING AT STEPS
THAT WILL BE TAKEN FORWARD AND
THEN OUR STAFF ASSISTED
APARTMENTS IN FULFILLING THE
STEPS IN THOSE PLANS AND WHAT
HAPPENS IF SOMEBODY FALLS DOWN
ON SOME GIVEN ELEMENT.
WHAT HAPPENS THAT SOMETHING'S
NOT WORKING?
THE PLANS ALSO I SHOULD ADD OR
IN ARE BROUGHT TO THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNSEL TO OUR COUNCIL
MEMBERS WHO ENDORSED THE PLAN --
AND THEN WE REVISIT THEM SO IF I
THEY NEED TO BE STRENGTHENED WE
CAN DO THAT OR MODIFIED IN
ADJUSTED THEY USUALLY HAVE ABOUT
A THREE YEAR IMPLEMENTATION
PERIOD.
AND THEN WE WILL ADJUST AS
NEEDED OR IF A NEW OPPORTUNITIES
ARISE -- AND BRING THAT BACK TO
THE COUNCIL AND WHAT IS IT JUST
LOOK LIKE WOULD THAT BE LIKE NEW
EQUIPMENT NEW TRAINING NEW
PEOPLE KNEW WHAT.
WELL FOR INSTANCE ONE EXAMPLE
WAS AN ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PLAN THAT LOOKED AT HOW -- TO IN
BED YOU KNOW AND THEN BRING
ACTIVE AT ACTIONS AROUND ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION TOGETHER.
THAT IS BEING REVISITED ACTUALLY
TO STRENGTHEN AND BROADEN THE
SCOPE TO A BROADER HEALTHY
TRANSPORTATION PLAN -- AND SO IT
REALLY IS A PROCESS OF LEARNING
AND GROWING THAT THE PLAN AS
POTENTIALLY NEW FUNDING SOURCES
BECOME AVAILABLE TO PARTNERS ARE
AVAILABLE TO DO THE WORK.
AND DO YOU HAVE THE VENT MARK
BENCHMARKS OR MILESTONES IS THAT
HAVE TO BE MET.
AND SIX MONTHS THIS HAS TO
HAPPEN IN EIGHT MONTHS THIS HAS
TO HAPPEN IS THERE SOME KIND OF
A SCHEDULE IF YOU WILL OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION.
YEAH THE ACTION PLANS TO INCLUDE
TIME LINES AND DELIVERABLES
WE'RE ALSO WORKING ON
IMPLEMENTING RESULTS BASED
ACCOUNTABILITY TOOLS INTO HOW
THESE ACTION PLANS ARE TRACKED
AND HOW PROGRESS AS MEASURED.
AND THEN IN ADDITION WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH WITH THEIR HEALTHY
COMMUNITY INDICATORS.
PROGRAM WHICH MEASURES -- KIND
OF WHAT COMMUNITY HEALTH LOOKS
LIKE AT A LOCAL LEVEL AND MAKE
SURE THAT THE WORK THAT WE'RE
DOING IS ALIGNED WITH WHAT WE
KNOW FROM LITERATURE BEST
PRACTICES TO ADVANCE THOSE
HEALTHY COMMUNITY ASPECTS OKAY
AS WE PROCEED THOUGH PLEASE WORK
WITH US PROVIDING INFORMATION
ABOUT IT.
WOULD WANT TO COME A YEAR FROM
NOW AND LOWER WORKING ON THIS
WE'RE WORKING ON THAT WERE
WORKING AND OTHER THINGS WE WANT
TO NEED TO KNOW THAT THIS IS
DONE THIS IS DONE IN THIS IS
DONE IN THIS IS TO DO.
AND THIS IS HALF WAY IN THIS IS
THREE QUARTERS.
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME THE
DISCIPLINE TO THE PROCESS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- IS THERE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS ISSUE.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
I CAN MORNING MEMBERS I WANTED
TO KNOW WHAT'S ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK A WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF RESOURCE IN THE
HEALTH AND ALL POLICIES PROGRAM.
I UP IS BEEN AN INTEGRAL PROJECT
THAT REALLY TRUST THE OTHER
DIVERSE AGENCIES TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE MOST CHALLENGING HELP
THIS.
BASING CALIFORNIA THESE ARE
THINGS ATTRIBUTED TO CLIMATE-CHANGE AND RACIAL BIAS JUST TO
NAME A COUPLE.
I'M CONTINUING TO SUPPORT THIS
IMPORTANT WORK WILL HELP
GENERATE EFFICIENT
RECOMMENDATIONS TO REDUCE THESE
DISPARITIES AS THE PAN HAS LONG
CHAMPIONED THE HEALTH AND ALL
POLICIES PROGRAM THROUGH PRIOR
LEGISLATION.
AND TO THE BUDGET PROCESS AND SO
WE HOPE THAT THE COMMITTEE WILL
APPROVE THIS ITEM WHEN THE TIME
COMES SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE ON PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY HEARING NONE -- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BEING WITH US --
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS TO HOLD
THIS ITEM OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR WORK.
THANK YOU -- THE NEXT ITEM.
EIGHTEEN IS THE THE FARM HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
ON THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME.
WELCOME TO THE MORNING TO MY
MANAGER MEMBERS MEANS DANIEL TO
STEAL WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT.
I'M CATHERINE EVEN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT I'M WITH
THE DIVISION OF FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE.
SO THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME
PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED TO
DEVELOP PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
IN NEED OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS OR AT RISK OF
CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS.
IN ORDER TO EXPEDITE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NO PLACE
LIKE HOME PROGRAM THE MEASURE
WAS PLACED ON THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NOVEMBER GENERAL
ELECTION BALLOT.
THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME ACT OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS PROPOSITION TWO AND WITH
SUBSEQUENTLY APPROVED BY THE
VOTERS.
THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME PROGRAM
ALLOWS FUNDS TO BE PROVIDED TO
COUNTIES WITH AT LEAST 5% OF THE
STATE'S HOMELESS POPULATION HAS
DEMONSTRATED AND HOMELESS POINT
TIME CAL.
BASED ON THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
POINT TIME CAN'T RESULTS TO
ELIGIBLE ALTERNATE PROCESS
COUNTIES.
ARE LOS ANGELES AND CLARICE AND
SAN DIEGO AND SAN JUSTO.
EACH SHE'S REQUESTING SEVEN
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND LOAN
FOR CASH FLOW NEEDS OF NO PLACE
LIKE HOME PROGRAM UNTIL.
PROGRAMS BONDS ARE ISSUED IN THE
FALL OF TWENTY NINETEEN AND WITH
THAT WILL ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE HAS.
COULD YOU EXPLAIN -- HOW THE?
SEVEN WHAT IS THE SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS LOAN GOING TO ACTUAL
WITH THE GAP AND WHEN YOU SAY
THAT -- THE BONDS WILL BE ISSUED
A BALL OF TWENTY NINETEEN WHEN
DO.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS THE TIMING FOR
THOSE BOND SO MATURE IF YOU CAN
CAN YOU FEEL IT ALL IN TIMELY.
SO SO WE'RE FILLING A GAP UNTIL
THOSE SPONSORED ISSUED OF THE
DEPARTMENT -- SURVEYED ARE
ALTERNATIVE PROCESS COUNTIES AND
ASK THEM TO GIVE US CASH FLOW
PROJECTIONS AND BASED ON THOSE
CASH FLOW PROJECTIONS WERE
LOOKING AT THOSE PROJECTS THAT
THEY'RE PROJECTING THEY NEED
CASH ON BEFORE OCTOBER OF TWENTY
NINETEEN IT'S OUR WERE
ANTICIPATING -- THAT THE BONDS
WOULD BE ISSUED BACK IN THAT
TIME FRAME AROUND NOTE OCTOBER.
WITHOUT WILL YOU.
WILL YOU STILL NEED.
A FUNDING AFTER OCTOBER OR IS IT
OCTOBER ONCE THE BONDS ARE
ISSUED THAT'S IT YOU HAVE THE
FUNDING RIGHT THE THE TREASURE
PERIODICALLY YOU KNOW THEY MAKE
ESTIMATE THEY WILL ISSUE.
AN INCREMENTAL BONDS BUT THAT
INCOME THAT WILL BE SUFFICIENT
TO REPAY THE GENERAL FUND LOUNGE
AND TO CONTINUE TO FUND THE CASH
FLOW OF THE ALTERNATIVE PROCESS
COUNTIES OVER THE NEXT TWELVE
MONTHS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ALEJO IN THE COMMENTS FINANCE.
DECREASE DEPARTMENT OF PROCESS
COUNTIES TO PRODUCE HOUSING
WITHOUT INTERRUPTION.
MEMBERS HOUSES REPORTED.
TO THIS COMMITTEE.
BUDGET COMMITTEE THEN.
YOUR COMPLETION THIS IS DONE
THIS IS PAID THIS IS NOT PAID
THESE ARE OUTSTANDING.
HOW DO WE GET THAT INFORMATION?
AS THE DEPARTMENT WE WORK WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND WINDOW
WHEN THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME
BONDS ARE IN FACT ISSUED.
A WE WILL WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO MAKE
THOSE TRANSACTIONS TO ENSURE
THAT THE GENERAL FUND LOAN IS
PAID IS DEAL F. THEN NOTIFY.
US THEN HOW DO WE KNOW ABOUT.
DANIELLE FRENCH PART IN THE
FINANCE SENATOR AND I'M GONNA
HAVE TO GET BACK TO IN THE EXACT
PROCESS UNFORTUNATELY I'M SORRY
I WAS.
I AM NOT FAMILIAR RIGHT NOW BUT
I DO BELIEVE THAT THERE IS SOME
KIND OF NOTIFICATION PROCESS.
WE NEED TO KNOW ORDER THAT'S GOT
TO BE HARD AND FAST [inaudible]
HOW FAR?
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY -- IS THERE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
ALL RIGHT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO HOLD THIS
ITEM OPEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
OKAY.
GOOD MORNING.
I'M SORRY GOOD MORNING.
RIVER WANTED ME TO GO YES.
I WAS JUST TRYING -- TO THEY
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE --
WELCOME AND TAKE IT AWAY.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MERRY BARCELONA ENGINEER NOW AND
I AM THE DIRECTOR OF THE
FINANCIAL INFORMATION SYSTEM FOR
CALIFORNIA.
AND I WANT TO START BY THINKING
EACH OF YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME
TO MEET WITH ME THIS WEEK --
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
PROJECT FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IT IS FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGING THE
WAY CALIFORNIA DOES BUSINESS --
SO IT'S MUCH MORE THAN THANAN
I. T. PROJECT AND AS I'VE
TESTIFIED TO IN THE PAST THE
BULK OF THE I. T. PROJECT ITSELF
IS IS COMPLETED 98% OF THE ITEMS
THAT WE HAD SET TO DEPLOY A HAVE
BEEN DEPLOYED IN ARE IN
PRODUCTION.
AND THE PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU
TODAY.
IS -- REALLY PRIMARILY TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED BY FTP AND OTHERS
THAT YOU HEARD TODAY.
WE ONLY HAVE SIX MILLION DOLLARS
IN THIS TOTAL REQUEST TO EXTEND
THE DEPLOYMENT OF THE FINAL AT
TECHNOLOGIES THAT NEED TO BE
IMPLEMENTED FOR THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE AND FOR THE
CASH.
FUNCTIONALITY COMING INTO THE
STATE.
THE REMAINING.
DOLLARS IN THIS B. C. P. REALLY
ARE TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF THE
DEPARTMENTS TO IDENTIFY AND WORK
WERE REALLY GONE FROM DEVELOPING
A SYSTEM TO OUR DEVELOPING THE
PEOPLE TO UTILIZE THE SYSTEM. TO
MAKING SURE THAT -- THE ERRORS
THAT AFTER HE BE YOU KNOW.
RAISED AS A CONCERN THAT WE
CONTINUE TO IDENTIFY THEM IN OUR
EXPEDITIOUSLY ABLE TO TO PUT
THEM IN -- TO PRODUCTION AND TO
TO STOP THEM FROM HAPPENING IN
SOME CASES IT'S GUARD RAILS
BECAUSE WE ARE HUMAN BEINGS
UTILIZING THE SYSTEM.
AND THERE ARE THERE ARE RULES
AND SOMETIMES YOU YOU YOU DON'T
FOLLOW THEM AND SO THERE'S
THERE'S A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT.
WAYS THAT WE WILL BE ADDRESSING
THE NEEDS OF THE DEPARTMENTS --
BUT WE WILL BE PROVIDING THESE
RESOURCES.
SOLELY FOR THAT FUNCTION THAT WE
ARE LOOKING AT IMPROVING OUR
REPORTING FUNCTIONALITY I WITH
THESE DOLLARS AS WELL AS
DRESSING.
THOSE VERY CRITICAL NEED TO THE
DEPARTMENTS.
THESE RESOURCES WILL ENABLE US
WE BELIEVE TO GET ALL OF THE
DEPARTMENTS MONTHS AND CLOSED IN
OUR SYSTEMS THERE'S THAT THERE'S
THIS DISCONNECT TO THEIRS.
THE SYSTEM ONE OF THE ISSUES IN
THE SYSTEM WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
GET THOSE DONE AND COMPLETED
THROUGH THE OCTOBER.
DEADLINE THAT THE CONTROLLER HAS
NOW WHETHER OR NOT THEY
PHYSICALLY ARE A 100% CLOSE ON
THE ACCOUNTING SIDE.
THAT LEAVES THE SYSTEM CONTROL
AND IS AN ACCOUNTING EXERCISE
AND SO WHILE.
THESE DOLLARS WILL HELP
ELIMINATE ALL OF THE SYSTEM
ISSUES THE SYSTEM CONCERNS.
THE ISSUES THAT THE DEPARTMENTS
ARE HAVING JUST UTILIZING THE
SYSTEM.
AND THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT AT
THE END OF THE DAY.
T. THAT I THE DEPARTMENTS WILL
HAVE A PERCENT CLOSE THEIR
MONTHS.
SO THAT'S WHAT THESE RESOURCES
ARE FOR EONS I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER.
THE QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND I AND I DO UNDERSTAND THAT
IT'S WE ARE LOOKING TO DO A
LONGER.
MORE IN DEPTH -- REVIEW OF THE
FISCAL SYSTEM ITSELF TALKING
ABOUT SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
ARE ALREADY DEPLOYED IN
IMPLEMENTED.
AND THEN TALKING ABOUT REALLY
THE ACCOUNTING COMPLEXITIES THAT
I FACE THE DEPARTMENTS.
OF THIS ALLEY -- HAVE ANY
COMMENTS PLEASE.
A BRIAN METZGER LA -- WE AGREE
WITH THE STAFF'S RECOMMENDATION
TO HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN -- WE DID
WANT TO FIRST ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IN OUR LAST
HEARING WE MENTIONED THAT THERE
WAS POTENTIALLY GOING TO BE A
NEW PROCESS FOR UPDATING THE
PROJECT THAT IT'S SINCE BEEN
CHANGED -- IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S WORKING ON A
NEW SPECIAL PROJECT REPORT TO
UPDATE.
THE PROJECT'S COST -- SCHEDULE
IN SCOPE -- THROUGH THE EXISTING
PROCESSES THAT WE ALREADY HAVE --
AND SO WE WANTED KNOWLEDGE AT
FIRST HOWEVER WE DO WANT TO
OUTLINE THE SHORT TIME LINE THE
LEGISLATURE IS GOING TO HAVE TO
CONSIDER AND TAKE ACTION ON THIS
PROPOSAL ONCE IT RECEIVES THAT
NEW SPECIAL PROJECT REPORT --
THE FISCAL PROJECT TEAM EXPECTS
TO SUBMIT A NEW S. P. R. TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY IN MID
MAY -- AFTER WHICH C. T. S. SAID
IT WILL NEED AT LEAST TEN DAYS --
TO APPROVE THE S. P. R. AND THAT
LEAVES THE LEGISLATURE LIKELY
NOT HAVING A UPDATED PROJECT
PLAN UNTIL MID TO LATE MAY.
I'M WITHOUT THAT UPDATED PROJECT
PLAN THE LEGISLATURE'S MISSING
SOME INFORMATION THAT IT WOULD
NEED TO EVALUATE THIS PROPOSAL --
SUCH AS FINANCIAL ANALYSIS
WORKSHEETS THAT SHOW HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION ARRIVED AT THE
AMOUNTS THAT ARE REQUESTED AND
THAT'S THIS BCP -- OUR OFFICE
WILL DO ITS BEST TO REVIEW THE
S. P. R. TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
FOR THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO MAKE A
DECISION -- IN ADDITION WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER -- REQUIRING THE
ADMINISTRATION TO IDENTIFY AND
CALCULATE THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
AND POSITIONS THAT ARE BEING
REQUESTED BY DEPARTMENTS OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS TO
TRANSACT IN FRISCO -- THE REASON
WE'RE ASKING FOR THAT IS IN
NINETEEN TWENTY THERE ARE AT
LEAST NINE DEPARTMENTS AS YOU'VE
SEEN HERE TODAY WITH THAT TO BE
THAT ARE REQUESTING THESE
RESOURCES.
I'M AND NOW DEPARTMENT OF
FISCALES REQUESTING ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AND WITHOUT THE
INFORMATION FROM THE S. P. R. TO
KNOW WHAT FUNDING OF POSITIONS --
COMPLEMENT OR DO NOT COMPLEMENT
THE RESOURCES THAT HAVE ALREADY
BEEN REQUESTED AS WELL AS
KNOWING WHAT PREVIOUS POSITIONS
HAVE ALREADY BEEN APPROVED IT'S
HARD TO CROSSWALK THAT.
TOO AND SO WITH THAT ALL ALL
TAKE ANY COMMENTS THAT YOU HAVE
A QUESTIONS [inaudible]
NUMBER FINANCE.
VETERAN PARMA FINANCE BE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL IS BUDGETED.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THESE
RESOURCES ARE VITAL FOR TO
ENSURING THAT THE DEPARTMENTAL
STAFF -- FOR CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
EDUCATION ON HOW TO CLOSE --
MONTH AND YEAR AND PROPERTIES.
WHAT WAS THE KEY?
MAYBE YEAH WHAT IS THE KEY IS IT
TRAINING OF PEOPLE OR IS IT
DEVELOPING MANUALS OR YOU KNOW.
WHAT WHAT WHAT IS IT WE'RE
TRYING?
TO COME UP WITH HERE SO THAT WE
CAN KEEP TRACK OF IT.
WE KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO WORK.
DID YOU HAVE PLANNED.
SO WE DO WE DO HAVE A PLAN
SENATOR AND WHAT WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED TO DATE HAS BEEN A
TRAIN THE TRAINER MODEL WHERE
FOLKS HAVE COME INTO THE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISCALE WE'VE DONE
A LOT OF ONLINE TRAINING.
AND WE'VE RECENTLY IN THE PAST
YEAR BROUGHT NEWS CREATED THESE
THINGS BECAUSE OF SUPPORT LABS
WERE DEPARTMENTS COME IN WITH
THEIR WORK.
AND SIT IN OUR OFFICES AND WE
HELP THEM GET THROUGH IT.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY WELL
WE'VE STANDARDIZED THE SYSTEM TO
THE EXTENT WE CAN.
WE STILL REMAIN.
THE FACT STILL REMAINS THAT WE
HAVE A HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO
DEPARTMENTS WITH A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY TWO DIFFERENT WAYS TO DO
THINGS.
THESE RESOURCES ARE GOING TO GO
AND HELP.
THEM.
LEARN THEIR PROCESSES AND READ
RIGHT THERE PROCESSES TO FIT
WITHIN THE SYSTEM WE CAN.
YOU KNOW PUT THE GUARD RAILS
HAPPEN WE CAN TELL THEM THIS IS
YOU KNOW HOW THE SYSTEM WORKS.
BUT THERE IS THIS DISCONNECT
pBETWEEN.
OKAY THEY'RE THE ONLY DEPARTMENT
IN THE STATE THAT DIES.
THIS TYPE OF A PROGRAM.
IT'S TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THAT
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE PROCESSES
AND PROCEDURES WITH THIS IS HOW
NOW WITHIN THE FISCAL SYSTEM.
AND SO THAT'S A LOT THAT'S WHY
AGAIN THESE RESOURCES ARE NOT.
FOR MORE SYSTEM WORK IN MORE IN
YOU KNOW DEVELOPING MILESTONES
IT REALLY IS DEVELOPING THE
PEOPLE HAVING A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHY ARE
DEPARTMENTS STRUGGLING IN
CERTAIN AREAS.
WHERE OTHERS?
ARE CLOSING THEIR MONTHS REALLY
EASILY SO WHAT WHAT IS THE
DIFFERENCE WHAT IS THE
DISTINCTION AND HOW CAN WE AS AN
ADMINISTRATION.
COLLECTIVELY COM -- TO A LONG
TERM SOLUTION TO HOW CAN WE IF
IT'S MANUALS FOR THOSE
DEPARTMENTS THAT MIGHT HELP THEM
PRODUCE THE MANUALS FOR THOSE
DEPARTMENTS.
IF IT'S MORE TRAINING OR
SPECIFIC HANDS ON KEYS WE'RE
LOOKING TO MOVE OUR ENVIRONMENT
UP INTO -- THE THE CLOUD.
SO THAT WE CAN SPIN UP TESTING
ENVIRONMENTS MUCH MORE QUICKLY
FOR THE DEPARTMENT SAID THAT
THEY'RE NOT HAVING TO WAIT.
I'M IN TAKE TURNS BECAUSE WE
ONLY HAVE A CERTAIN CAPACITY ON
OUR PROMISES SO THOSE ARE THE
TYPES OF THINGS WILL BE ABLE TO
DO WITH.
THIS WITH THESE RESOURCES SO
MOVE MORE OF OUR SYSTEM INTO THE
CLOUD TO ALLOW FOR THE TRAINING
AND TESTING THE DEPARTMENT SO
DESPERATELY ARE ASKING US -- FOR
AS WELL AS THE BOOTS ON THE
GROUND IN THEIR DEPARTMENTS.
JUST TO CLARIFY WE ARE NOT
ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL -- F. T.
EASE ON THE STATE SIDE THESE ARE
ALL CONTRACT DOLLARS WE'RE
LOOKING FOR BECAUSE AGAIN WE
LOOK.
TO PROVIDE THE TRAINING PROVIDE
THE RESOURCES BE THEM HARD
COPIES OR THROUGH BETTER ROBUST
TRAINING BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY -- WE WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR
RESOURCES AT FISCAL ON GOING
[inaudible]
OKAY.
QUESTIONS HELLO WE THANK YOU ALL
FOR ENGAGING IN THE DISCUSSIONS
THAT WE'VE HAD -- I'M GONNA
SUPPORT THIS BUT WELL I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT THE RECOMMENDATION.
OF BUT THIS.
THIS BILL DOES DOES BEG FOR A
DEEPER DIVE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
YEAH -- I GUESS AS YOU'RE MOVING
FORWARD TO SAY OF YOU WANT TO DO.
YOU KNOW FOR THE DEPARTMENTS TO
SEE WHAT IS THERE.
WHAT IS THE PARTICULAR PROBLEM
FACING THEM INDIVIDUAL
DEPARTMENTS?
THE BY NOW YOU HAVE A GOOD SENSE
OF WHAT THE ISSUES ARE. FOR MANY
DEPARTMENT SO I'M NOT SURE 80%
OF THE TICKETS THAT COME INTO MY
SYSTEM TODAY.
OUR HOW TO QUESTIONS SO HOW DO I
DO X. Y. Z. OKAY SO THEY ARE NOT
THE SYSTEM IS KICKING OUT THIS
ERROR I DO GET SOME OF THE WHAT
DOES THIS.
MEAN AND SOMETIMES THAT ERROR IS.
YEAH YOU YOU ENTERED SOMETHING
IN THE WRONG COLUMN YOU KNOW SO
SOMETIMES IT'S HUMAN ERROR AND
SOMETIMES I DO HAVE AN AREA THAT
WE HAVE TO GO IN AND FIX.
IT SO A LOT OF THE QUESTIONS THE
BOULDER THE TICKETS ATMIAMI
DEPARTMENT RECEIVES FROM.
THE HUNDRED FIFTY TWO CLIENTS
ARE REALLY ON HOW TO DO THEIR
JOBS.
AND SO WE ARE IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
BECAUSE AGAIN THEY HAVE THE THE
ACCOUNTANTS FOR FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ALONG WITH.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH -- SOME OF
THAT THE STAFF AT THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE.
WE ARE DEALING WITH THOSE HOW TO
ACCOUNTING AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
IS GOING TO HELP US IT WAS JUST
YOU KNOW WE NEED TO BE ABLE. TO
DO WHATEVER TRAINING ON NEEDS TO
HAPPEN ON HOW TO UTILIZE THIS
SYSTEM.
REMEMBER WE'RE GOING FROM A
TRANSACTIONAL BASED SYSTEM. TO
AN ACCOUNTING SYSTEM S THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME IN THIRTY YEARS
THAT MANY OF THE ACCOUNTANTS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE HAD
TO BALANCE LEDGERS AND TO DO THE
ACCOUNTING -- ALL UP FRONT.
AND FOR THEM TO UNDERSTAND HOW
HOW EACH OF THESE LETTERS WORK
SO.
WE JUST NEED TO PROVIDE THAT
ADDITIONAL.
THOSE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. TO
PROVIDE THE SUPPORT SO THAT
AGAIN.
THE THE TECHNOLOGY THAT WE'VE
INVESTED IN CAN BE SUCCESSFULLY
APPLIED.
AND WOULD YOU SAY.
IN YOUR OPINION [inaudible]
THAT.
YOUR SEEN ENOUGH OF THE BENEFITS
[inaudible]
OF THIS.
BY THE STATE.
WOULD YOU SAY THAT THAT REALLY
SHOWS THAT WERE.
DOING THE RIGHT THINGS OR ARE WE
STILL.
SORRY TESTING TO SEE WHAT NOW I
I FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT THIS HAS
BEEN AN INCREDIBLE INVESTMENT
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE BUDGET HAS BEEN AN
INCREDIBLE.
AND YOU RECEIVED A CREDIBLE
BENEFITS ONLY A BUDGET THAT IS
BEFORE YOU WAS CREATED.
THROUGH THE USE OF THAT THE
HYPERION THAT THE FISCAL SYSTEMS
OKAY.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WAS ABLE TO PRODUCE A
BUDGET FOR THE LEGISLATURE IN
FOR THE PUBLIC.
AS ENACTED WITH THE SAME LEVEL
OF DETAIL THAT YOU GET IN
JANUARY SO OF COURSE JANUARY IS
THAT FIRST SALVO FROM THE
GOVERNOR SAYING THIS IS WHAT I
THINK THE BUDGET SHOULD BE.
BUT THEN AFTER ALL OF THE WORK
THAT THE LEGISLATURE DIES THERE
IS OT -- THERE HAD NOT BEEN A
SINGLE DOCUMENT THEY COULD SHOW
YOU THIS IS THE GOVERNING
DOCUMENT FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
YOU HAD TO GO TO CHANGE BOOK YOU
HAD TO GO TO THESE OTHER SYSTEMS.
FISCAL NOW PROVIDES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE POSTED ON
THEIR WEBSITE.
AND IT IS AVAILABLE TO BOTH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE PUBLIC
I THE WE SO WE HAVE FULLY
IMPLEMENTED THE BUDGETING SYSTEM
WE HAVE FULLY IMPLEMENTED THE
PROCUREMENT SYSTEM FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
SO NOT ONLY CAN YOU --
DEPARTMENT SOLICIT BIDS -- FRAUD
GOODS AND SERVICES FROM VENDORS
THROUGH THE SYSTEM. NINETY SEVEN
THOUSAND VENDORS HAVE UTILIZED
THE SYSTEM TO REGISTER.
AND ALL OF THE SMALL BUSINESSES
AND DISABLE BUSINESS VETERAN
ENTERPRISES HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
CERTIFY FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER
IN THIS SYSTEM -- INSTEAD OF A
PAPER PROCESS SO THE KELLY
PROCURE WHICH WHAT WITH WHAT
THEY CALL.
THE CALIPERS GENERAL SERVICES IS
COMPLETE.
THE MODIFIED A CRUEL FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
ACCOUNTING PIECE OF THE
DEPARTMENT -- ACCOUNTING IS
BUILT AND IS BEING UTILIZED BY
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND AND USERS.
THAT IS WHERE WE ARE SEEING SOME
OF THE STRUGGLES AND SOME OF THE
EDUCATION IN THE LEARNING CURVE.
AS WELL AS SOME OF THE YOU KNOW
IT'S WITH A LARGE ACCOUNTING
SYSTEM SHIFT.
ON SOME OF THE BUGS WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK OUT FOR THE
NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS.
BUT ALL IN ALL WE HAVE PRODUCED
YET THE FINANCIAL INFORMATION
SYSTEM FOR CALIFORNIA IS A
SYSTEM OF SYSTEMS WE HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY DEPLOYED HYPERION.
SUCCESSFULLY.
PROJECT MANAGEMENT TOOL THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
UTILIZES FOR ITS CONSTRUCTION
MANAGEMENT CALLED PRIME.
WE HAVE SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED
THE PROCUREMENT SO THERE'S A
NUMBER OF WHAT OTHERWISE WOULD
BE IN ANY OTHER DEPARTMENT.
HUGE IT PROJECTS THEY ARE HUGE
PROJECTS THEY HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFULLY DELIVERED IN ARE
BEING UTILIZED TODAY.
SO WHAT REALLY REMAINS IS THE
CASH BOOK OF RECORDS.
AND NOT KEYS ARE IS WHAT WE ARE
EXTENDING OUT SO AGAIN OF THE
PROPOSAL THAT IS BEFORE YOU
THERE'S SIX MILLION DOLLARS THAT
WE ARE ASKING. FOR TO EXTEND
BASICALLY TO EXTEND CONTRACT
RESOURCES. TO ALLOW FOR THE
ADDITIONAL TESTING BUT TE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE -- WANTS TO
HAVE IN THE SYSTEM BUT THEN ALSO
TO ALLOW FOR DEPARTMENTS TO COME
IN AND DO SOME ADDITIONAL
TESTING ON THE NEW FUNCTIONALITY
BEFORE IT IS RELEASED.
SO.
LIKE I SAID THE BULK OF THESE
DOLLARS ARE REALLY. FOR THAT
EDUCATION AND HOW DO WE REALLY
MAXIMIZE THE BENEFITS OF THE
SYSTEM THE OTHER THING THAT IS
BEEN AN INCREDIBLE SUCCESS.
FOR THE FISCAL SYSTEM THAT -- IS
I BELIEVE CHANGING A LOT OF THE
DIALOGUE ON HOW WE WILL BE ABLE
TO TALK ABOUT.
FINANCE FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS OUR TRANSPARENCY
WEBSITE.
SO IF YOU'RE OPEN FISCALE WORK
TO MY WEBSITE FISCALE LOTS YET
YIELDING YOU CLICK ON IT YOU CAN
SEE EXPENDITURE DATA. FOR IT'S
NOT A 100% OF THE DEPARTMENT'S
YET BECAUSE THE SIXTY FOUR
AREN'T OP THAT JUST CAME ON IN
JULY.
BUT I BELIEVE I'VE GOT EIGHTY
EIGHT THE BULK OF EIGHTY EIGHT
DEPARTMENTS -- UP.
ON THERE ALREADY WE WILL
CONTINUE TO BRING ON THE
REMAINING DEPARTMENTS THE TARGET
IS THE SUMMER THIS SUMMER.
AND THEN YOU WILL BE ABLE TO AN
ANYBODY AGAIN CAN UTILIZE THIS
INFORMATION THEY CAN DOWNLOAD
THE DATA THAT THEY CAN SLICE IT
AND DICE IT THE WAY THAT THEY
SEE FIT.
BUT THIS IS HUGE HUGE
IMPROVEMENTS.
IN BOTH TRANSPARENCY FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT IN THE
ABILITY TO BETTER MANAGE FOR OUR
AGENCIES FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
IT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FOR
THE LEGISLATURE.
SO MY SENSE AS NOT KNOWING.
TECHNOLOGY THE WAY THAT YOU DO
BUT MY SENSE IS THAT.
THIS IS A REALLY GREAT MORE
SOPHISTICATED.
PROGRAM.
BUT THE DOWNSIDE HAS BEEN.
THAT -- THE DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS WERE NOT PREPARED
[inaudible] TO IMPLEMENT.
VARYING DEGREES OF OF SUCCESS IN
THE VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS MATT
WOULD SAY THAT.
AT THIS POINT MOVING FORWARD --
YOU KNOW DO YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY
SENSE OF ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
THAT WE'RE GONNA NEED. TO
OPERATE FISCAL.
THIS IS WHAT WE ARE ESTIMATING
FOR THE NEXT THREE YEARS THIS
THIRTY SAYS THAT THIS THIRTY ONE
PLUS YEAH -- RIGHT AND IT'S IT'S
A THREE YEAR PROPOSAL SO IT'S
THIRTY SEVEN IN THE FIRST YEAR
TWENTY FOUR POINT SEVEN IN THE
SECOND AND NINETY POINT FOUR IN
THAT THIRTY YEAR.
AND AGAIN THAT IS.
WHAT WE ARE ASKED?
TAKE FOR BOTH THE ART
DEPARTMENTS TO HAVE A BETTER
FLOW IN UNDERSTANDING OF OF THE
SYSTEM FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE BETTER TRAINING.
PRESS TO GET BETTER TRAINING
PROGRAMS FOR OUR OWN STAFF IN
PLACE BECAUSE REMEMBER THIS IS A
NEW SYSTEM STATEWIDE MY STAFF
ONLY HAVE FOUR YEARS EXPERIENCE
UTILIZING IT SO WE'VE BEEN
GROWING AND LEARNING.
WITH THE SYSTEMS DEPLOYMENT OUR
CONTRACTORS HAVE FIFTEEN YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE UTILIZING PEOPLE
SOFT.
I HAVE TO SAY THAT -- AS WE
BRING ON NEW EMPLOYEES INTO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS OUR
GRADUATING IN COMING TO THE
STATE FROM.
I'M VERY STATE SCHOOLS SACKS
STATES A GREAT EXAMPLE THEY
TRAIN ALL OF THEIR ACCOUNTS
USING PEOPLE SAW.
THESE FOLKS THAT ARE COMING TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR THE
FIRST TIME ARE WALKING IN THE
DOOR AND HELPING THESE
DEPARTMENTS.
WITHOUT ANY WITHOUT ANY ISSUES
SO SO THERE IS THIS CHANGE
MANAGEMENT PART.
BUT WHEN YOU'RE COMING IN
WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING OF THE
SYSTEM WE NOW ARE WE HAVE
EVIDENCE THAT WOULD INDICATE
THAT THE SYSTEM.
DOES IN FACT.
DO YOU SIR CAN PRODUCE -- FASTER
RESULTS AND MORE.
YOU KNOW THE BENEFITS OF THE
MORE DETAIL WITH WITHOUT THE
STRUGGLES AT SOME OF SOME OF OUR
CURRENT STATE STAFF HOUSE.
AND THIS IS A HUGE MORE THAN AN
I. T. IMPLEMENTATION THIS HIS.
LIGHT I I CAN'T STE STRONGLY
SAVE ENOUGH THAT WE
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE WAY
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE DO
THEIR JOBS.
EVERY SINGLE DAY WHAT THEY DO
COMING AND WE'RE CHANGING HOW
THEY GO ABOUT DOING IT.
SO -- YES SO I I'M NOT LOOKING.
TO YOU KNOW ASK FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR AT FOR WHAT FOR
WHAT THE PROJECT IS TODAY.
I WILL NOTE FOR THAT THE
COMMITTEE THAT WE DO HAVE NINE
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE DEFERRED
CURRENTLY FROM BEING INCLUDED IN
THE SYSTEM.
WHEN THOSE DEPARTMENTS DO COME
ON WHEN THERE'S THE USEFUL LIFE
OF THEIR SYSTEMS COME TO AN END
AND THEY LOOK TO TRANSITION? TO
TO THE FISCAL SYSTEM I DON'T
HAVE A CHRIS.
VENTURE A GUESS THAT I WOULD
NEED TO COME BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR THE ON BOARDING
THE CONFIGURATION AND THAT THE
TRANSITION OF THESE BECAUSE
THESE ARE BIG DEPARTMENTS.
CALTRANS CDC OUR WATER RESOURCES
THE ON THE YOUR SOME OF THAT.
SOME OF THE LARGER --
DEPARTMENTS SO WE CAN EXPECT A
REQUEST FOR RESOURCES TO COVER
THOSE NINE ADDITIONAL READY PART
FOR THE ON BOARDING PASS AND
THIS IS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
BEEN A LITTLE BIT CONFUSING TO
ME IS.
THERE'S RESOURCES TO FISCALE BUT
THEN THERE'S INDIVIDUAL
DEPARTMENTS THAT ALSO COME TO US
REQUESTING MONEY TO STAFF UP
RIGHT -- SO DO YOU EXPECT.
THAT WE WOULD ALSO HEAR FROM.
EITHER OF DEPARTMENTS ARE
ALREADY ON BOARD OR THE NINE
ADDITIONAL DEPARTMENTS THAT THEY
WILL ALSO COME INDIVIDUALLY. TO
ASK FOR RESOURCES.
TO CARRY OUT THE FISCAL.
I HAVE IMPLEMENT YEAH I'D HAVE
TO DEFER TO TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FOR THAT.
BUT GENERALLY SPEAKING THE
RESOURCES THAT WE ARE ASKING FOR
ARCH SUPPORT THAT THE STATEWIDE
SYSTEM.
AND WHAT I HEARD FROM.
HAVE LIKE IF TO BE.
IN READING SOME OF THE OTHER BE
CITIES IT APPEARS THAT THEY'RE
LOOKING -- FOR RESOURCES THAT
WILL ENABLE THEM TO DEAL WITH
THE ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD THAT IS --
IN SOME CASES REQUIRED.
IN THAT IN THE SYSTEM ONE OF THE
KEY ONES IS SMALL TO SMALL
MEDIUM DEPARTMENTS -- WILL HAVE
VERY SMALL ACCOUNTING SHOPS AND
AS A RESULT.
FISKE OUT NOW IT'S NOT A NEW
REQUIREMENT BUT FIST CALLIN
FORCES YOUR SEPARATION OF DUTIES
SO I CANNOT GO IN AND PUT IN A
REQUISITION AND BUY SOMETHING.
AND THEN ALSO BE THE APPROVER.
THERE NEEDSTO BE A SEPARATE
BODIES TO BE ABLE TO DO PROPER
ACCOUNTING.
I SAW SOME OF THEM.
ALL DEPARTMENTS ARE ASKING FOR
RESOURCES FOR THAT TYPE OF THING
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY I
CAN'T SPEAK TO IT.
THE CONDITION OF THE ACCOUNTING
OFFICE IS A AND THE OTHER
DEPARTMENTS.
A SO WE EVALUATE REQUESTS FROM
APARTMENTS RELATED DEFENSE GODS
ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS AND IF
THEY HAVE A UNIQUE SITUATION
THAT DOES REQUIRE MORE RESOURCES
WE RECOMMEND THOSE FOR APPROVAL --
BUT WE WE CAN'T REALLY PROJECT
OUT THAT WE KNOW TODAY THAT
THEY'RE GONNA BE ANY DEPARTMENTS
ARE WE GONNA BE COMING FORWARD
IN FUTURE YEARS.
MORE RESOURCES RELATED TO FRISCO --
AND RELATED TO THE REPORTING
THAT ELLIE I MENTIONED EARLIER --
THERE IS A SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AS PART
OF THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINTEEN
BUDGET ACT.
THAT DOES REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE.
TO REPORT ON OTHER COSTS THAT
HAVE BEEN REQUESTED RELATED TO
FIX GAL OUTSIDE OF THE SCOUTS
BUT SO THAT INFORMATION IS GOING
TO BE COLLECTED AFTER THE AFTER
THE PROJECT IT IS IS OVER AND WE
CAN.
ACTUALLY GET A FULL.
THE HOTEL.
WHEN IS THAT -- IT'S GONNA BE
THAT THE THE PROPOSAL WAS FOR
THAT THAT WILL BE COMPLETED IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY SO IN.
TWENTY IS WHEN WE CAN HEAR THAT
BUT THAT WILL BE AFTER IT'S ALL.
YES BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO THE
BILL THE REQUIREMENT IS THAT WE
WE PROVIDE ALL OF THE
INFORMATION AND I CAN PROVIDE
ALL OF WE CAN PROVIDE ALL THE
INFORMATION UNTIL THE PROJECT IS.
COMPLETE [inaudible]
YES.
JUST TO CLARIFY THAT -- THE THE
SUPPLEMENT REPORTING LANGUAGE
THAT -- FINANCES REFERRING TO
DOES SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS
ADDITIONAL COSTS RELATED TO THE
INTEGRATED SOLUTION I BELIEVE
COSTS FOR DEPARTMENTS TO
TRANSACT IN FISCAL.
WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S FINANCES
APPROACH TO TO DOING THIS IS TO
LET THE PROJECT INTER KIND OF
THE MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS
PHASE AND THEN START AGGREGATING
THOSE NUMBERS.
IS IS DIFFERENT FROM WHAT THE
ART LANGUAGE ACTUALLY SAYS SO IF
THE LEGISLATURE WOULD LIKE TO
CLARIFY THAT IN SUPPLEMENT
REPORTING LANGUAGE COULD DO SO.
ACTION ITEM TO WRESTLE WITH THE
HOST OF WE DO GET SOMETHING
CLEAR -- UNIT. TOO MUCH IS TOO
VAGUE. FOR ME TO GET MY HANDS ON
IT RIGHT NOW [inaudible]
YEAH.
YEAH I THINK THAT'S PART OF THE
THE ON GOING IF IT WAS ALL
COMING THROUGH FISCAL SAYING.
THIS IS WHAT WE NEED THIS IS HOW
EVERY DAY.
BUT EVERY DEPARTMENT NEEDS WITH
THE RESOURCES ARE THEY GOING TO
BE NEEDED.
WHETHER IT'S TRAINING THE
DEPARTMENT STAFF FOR YOUR
OVERSIGHT OR YOU KNOW.
RESOURCES FOR YOUR ROLE.
IT JUST SEEMS TO BE COMING IN.
ADDISON DIFFERENT.
FROM DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS AT
DIFFERENT TIMES RATHER THAN.
HERE'S HERE'S THE TOTAL PICTURE.
AND THIS IS HOW WE AIM TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYBODY HAS THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO IMPLEMENT
AND I THINK THAT'S AS PART OF MY
SORT OF FRUSTRATION.
AND WANTING TO BE HELPFUL.
BUT JUST YOU KNOW ONE WEEK IT'S
THIS AND OTHER WEEK IT'S THAT
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENT AND THEN
ALL COMING. FOR EXAMPLE DO YOU
TO SAY YES THIS IS.
THIS IS SOMETHING WE NEED AND
AFTER ALL THESE DEPARTMENTS THAT
HAVE -- COME ON BOARD SEEMS TO
ME WE SHOULD HAVE A BETTER IDEA
AT LEAST OF THE REMAINING.
AFTER ALL THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE.
SO DISTANT ISSUE [inaudible]
TO ANYMORE.
OKAY -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALL YOUR HARD WORK -- STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO HOLD ITS
OPEN PUBLIC COMMENT.
HEARING NONE.
OKAY CLICHES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
VERY EFFICIENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH EVERYBODY